oui bienvenue à part une autochtone ici
c'est melissa maulin dupuis cette
semaine j'ai reçu une question de
aurélie qui me demande quels sont les
organismes qui oeuvrent dans l'activisme
féministe autochtones au canada et pour
commencer aurélie il y as femmes
autochtones du canada qui est un groupe
qui va unir toutes les groupes
provinciaux de femmes autochtones au
québec on a la chance d'avoir femmes
autochtones du québec qui est un groupe
extrêmement actif depuis 1976 qu'elle à
la défense des droits des femmes
autochtones qui va avoir aussi la
capacité d'aller dans les communautés de
donner des ateliers de sensibilisation
qui ont même une voix auprès de l'apn qu
elles pour pouvoir aider à répondre aux
questions liées aux femmes auprès des
chefs des communautés
c'est un organisme qui est très respecté
quand même fait de la représentation à
l'onu
les femmes se réunissent à chaque année
il faut vraiment en sorte que la cause
des femmes autochtones avance
ensuite c'est certain qu'on a cette
question là où qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
défendre au milieu urbain parce qu'on
pense souvent aux femmes en milieu des
communautés les femmes en milieu urbain
elles peuvent bénéficier les services
qui viennent de décembre d'amitié
autochtone à montréal on a deux centres
d'amitié il ya leçon d'amitié qui qu'on
appelle né le french saint tin et il ya
le centre de métier qu'on appelle aussi
le real autochtone et le monde et ses
centres laon des cercles de femmes qui
elles peuvent aussi se mobiliser pour
pouvoir aider les femmes à s'unir à
briser l'isolément justement défendre
des questions qui peuvent être plus
politique liée à habiter à montréal ce
sont des mythes il se retrouve un peu
partout dans les grands centres urbains
au québec et fait partie du grand
regroupement des centres d'amitié
autochtones
ce sont des groupes qui vont prendre en
charge la question des femmes est
souvent mal an le féministe autochtone
et c'est un angle qui est extrêmement
inclusif des hommes des enfants des
questions familiales lotion se retrouve
au sein même des communautés
il va ya voir même des cercles de
couture des cuisines collectives des
groupes d'aînés qui elles aussi vont
pouvoir travailler à régler des
questions féministes au sein des
communautés
et quand on veut encore aller plus loin
on peut regarder des groupes de
mobilisation tel cadeau
qui sont des groupes qui se sont unis
autour d'une idéologie féministe mais
pour protéger l'environnement pour
protéger justement les questions liées
au futur de nos enfants et la protection
aussi des droits des hommes et des
femmes
donc oui existe beaucoup d'organismes et
existe aussi beaucoup de groupes qui
s'unissent pour ces questions féministes
mais c'est sûr que c'est d'un point de
vue des femmes autochtones et c'est des
points de vue qui se transforme grâce
aux alliances grâce au partenariat qu'on
fait avec des organismes non autochtones
j'espère aurait dit que ça a répondu à
ta question
j'espère que vous n'hésiterez pas à nous
envoyer d'autres questions et à partager
ses vidéos
c'est une belle semaine